the top leaders of china's ruling
communist party are holding a key
meeting that's expected to further
tighten president xi jinping's grip on
power behind closed doors she is set to
lay the groundwork for an unprecedented
third term in office that would cement
his position as china's most powerful
leader in recent history
chinese president xi jinping hasn't left
china for over 21 months partly because
of covet 19 but also because he's
focused on building his power base at
home
the upcoming plenum is an opportunity to
set the tone in his bid to become
china's long-term ruler his message is
that china is a superpower and the rest
of the world better know it
the chinese people will never allow any
foreign forces to bully oppress or
enslave us
anyone who dares try to do that will
have their heads bashed and bloodied
against the great wall of steel forged
by over 1.4 billion chinese people
the plenum gathers 370 top communist
party cadres from politics and the
military the most important item on the
agenda is a resolution looking back at
key events in the party's hundred-year
history it gives the party the ability
to shape the narrative of its history as
it sees fit and enshrined president xi's
role as leader
it's only the third time this has
happened
the previous two resolutions were
introduced by the founder of the
people's republic of china mao zedong
and the architect of the economic
reforms that boosted the economy deng
xiaoping
she wants to show that he's an equally
important leader transforming china into
a global power
he wants to make his power felt across
all of chinese society
he has boosted the military and launched
a crackdown that has muzzle tech tycoons
like alibaba's jack ma
in recent weeks she has been stepping up
pressure on the sovereign island of
taiwan which china considers its own and
the world is watching to see how
tensions unfold
the plenum which runs until thursday
lays the groundwork for the crucial 2022
party congress where she is expected to
secure his position for at least another
five years
he faces challenges economic growth is
slowing down amid an energy crunch
supply chain disruption and fears of a
crisis in the country's real estate
sector
challenges that need to be overcome if
he is to prove himself equal to chairman
mao and don xiaoping
and let's bring in fabian kretschmer
in beijing for us um fabian this morning
the communist party central committee
gathered behind closed doors as we just
heard i know we're not in there but what
can we expect from the meeting
well i mean it might sound like a rather
bureaucratic meeting but indeed it's
crucial
for seating ping to lay the groundwork
of his
power extended he wants to stay in power
for a third term that's unprecedented
and what we can expect is that the
members of the central committee they
will adopt a so-called historic
resolution to praise the historic
achievements of the communist party in
the last 100 years since its founding
what that means is basically a rewriting
of history
forexing pink uh to use for its own
agenda
and um it's quite remarkable that uh
those um historical resolutions have
only been passed uh three times one time
uh under mao zedong that was in 1945 and
he used a chance to sideline his
opponents with that resolution later
under deng xiaoping he used a historic
resolution to reflect on history and
also reflect on the party's mistakes but
now we basically have a historic
resolution to rewrite history uh to lay
the groundwork for xi jinping's power to
um yeah keep on going
and what did today's events then mean
for president xi jinping this resolution
and so on how does that help him
well i mean it's quite a sensitive issue
here um no chinese leader has ever
stayed in power for a third office since
mao zedong and um after mao's death um
the party
decided that
there should not be any excessive power
there should not be any excessive
personality cult and um xi jinping is
basically the first politician to change
that he's the most powerful leader since
mao zedong and
basically the propaganda narrative here
so the message is that he's the leader
to lead the chinese nation um to become
great again and become strength uh
strong again and there's no alternative
to him
and how much do the 1.3 billion members
of the chinese nation actually get to
know about this meeting
well it's highly controlled first of all
the meeting is taking place behind
closed doors i mean not even we
journalists have any access there will
be a news handout in the coming days and
but what the public
notices uh first of all is an increase
of personality cult in the recent weeks
and months the state media have
exaggerated their praise of xi jinping
it became almost absurd i mean it's
comparable to the rhetoric of
the north korean regime almost and um
also what i find remarkable is that if
you talk to people on the street
especially in the countryside most of
them are not really aware that xi
jinping is the first
leader who will change the law to become
a de facto leader for life and
i think right now is a really a
sensitive time and you can really feel
that the authorities are quite nervous
and yeah
so um exciting times to watch out what's
happening in the next days and thank you
so much for following them for us fabian
kretschmer reporting live from beijing
you